le printemps s'est installé à moscou et
en russie le mois de mai annonce
l'arrivée de plusieurs grands congés
festif d'où ce message du président
vladimir poutine qui demande à son
peuple de ne pas céder car la situation
est critique des scènes comme celle ci
filmé par un médecin ou soins intensifs
sont devenus trop familière et tourne en
boucle à la télévision
mais ce dont on parle moins ce sont des
médecins qui meurent tous les jours
ce mémorial improvisé à
saint-pétersbourg en dénombre déjà 70 ce
complexe le cardiologue à l'excès et
relais parmi eux il y avait là chef des
urgences à la cité des étoiles où
s'entraînent les cosmonautes et où il y
a eu une éclosion elle s'est jetée de la
fenêtre d'un hôpital selon ses collègues
une deuxième médecin a aussi fait une
chute similaire d'un immeuble dans les
mêmes circonstances
il repose dans un état critique ce qui
en dit long sur la gestion de la
pandémie en russie où le virus est
encore loin d'être contenu le kremlin a
dû même prolongé de trois semaines le
confinement de la population
une nouvelle désastreuse pour les
travailleurs sans revenus qui dans
certaines villes ont violé les mesures
pour manifester à leurs risques et
périls car jusqu'ici les russes qui
travaillait pour le secteur privé n'ont
pas reçu un sou du gouvernement poussé
le politicien de mettet goudkov nous
nous sommes dit le guide
le président a plutôt demandé aux
entrepreneurs comme anastasia tattoo
lova de continuer de payer leurs
employés comme si de rien n'était elle
avait pourtant confronté le président en
personne au début de la crise pour le
supplier de changer sa stratégie mais en
vain quand notre équipe à moscou leur
rencontre et elle venait de mettre à
pied 1800 employés sans aucune
compensation
oui si lyon
toute sa tête a pas les édiles va perdre
leur 610 goudkov et surtout leur
confiance celle d'un peuple qu'il veut
convaincre de le laisser gouverner pour
les 15 prochaines années
ici tu as marre altérer ce que
radio-canada morère